My name is Dr. Steven Lewis
and today I will introduce
you to the standard questions
to ask when obtaining
a patient's gynecological
and obstetrical history.
Today's objectives
are to identify and
utilize the standard
questions asked to female
patients regarding
their gynecological
history from menarche
through menopause.
To identify and utilize
the standard questions
asked to non-pregnant
female patients regarding
their obstetrical
history. to identify and
utilize the standard
questions asked to pregnant
patients regarding
their obstetrical
history, current pregnancy,
including postpartum.
Describe the basics of
a pap smear including
indications for and how the
screening test is performed.
In today's lecture, we
will only be discussing
questions that should be
asked regarding the patient's
gynecological and obstetrical
history only. We will
not go over general history
questions to ask a patient
as part of your general
history and physical exam.
In the female, there
are different stages of
life as represented on
this slide. It is important
to note that not every
female enters each
stage of life. For example,
some females choose
not to become pregnant.
The questions we will
discuss today encompass
many of these stages.
We will now discuss the
standard questions to
ask female patients
regarding their gynecological
history from menarche
through menopause.
Why do we ask about the
patient's
gynecological history?
One reason is to
identify any areas
of concern that the
patient may have.
Also to inquire about
the status of routine
gynecological
screening examinations.
And this allows the physician
to address any areas
of concern, discuss
sensitive topics, and answer
any questions. It also
provides an opportunity to
provide patient education
and anticipatory guidance.
On this slide, you
will see a list of
topics which should
be covered when
obtaining the
gynecological history.
We will now go through each
one of these in more detail.
When discussing
gynecological symptoms
and complaints,
some common areas to
address include the
breast, thyroid,
vulval vaginal,
pelvic, and colorectal.
We will review the
breast in more detail
when discussing
the breast section.
On the slide, you will
see a list of questions to
ask regarding any dysfunction
of the thyroid gland.
Through these questions,
you are assessing for any
potential symptoms of
hypothyroidism or hyperthyroidism.
Depending on answers to
these questions and your
physical exam, further
workup may be warranted.
With questions regarding
the vulvovaginal,
pelvic, and colorectal areas,
You're assessing for any
symptoms regarding discharge,
which could be a sign
of a possible infection,
masses or lesions,
which could be a sign
of various etiologies,
including cancer,
pain, which could be
a sign of numerous
different etiologies, or
abnormal bleeding, which
can be either vaginally
or rectally, as
these could be signs of
underlying pathology.
One of the most
common gynecological
complaints seen in
clinical practice revolves
around a patient's
menstrual cycle.
When discussing with the
patient about her menstrual
cycle, the first question
is typically about menarche.
Menarche is the age at which
a female begins menstruation.
When discussing
specifically about
menstruation, you begin
by inquiring about the
first day of their
last menstrual period.
Additional questions
include how often do
they have their menses
and how long does
it last, as well as
how heavy the flow is.
The best way for a
patient to quantify the
flow of her menses is
to describe it by the
number of pads or tampons
used daily or hourly.
It is also important
to ask if there is
any bleeding in between
menses, any pain
with menses, and any
bleeding with ******
*********** or after
****** ***********.
Menopause is one
year without menses.
When inquiring about
menopause, you begin
by asking when they
stopped menstruating
and how old they were
when this occurred.
You want to assess for any
symptoms of menopause. Some
common symptoms include
hot flashes, night sweats,
sleep disturbances,
vaginal dryness and irritation,
urinary frequency, depression,
mood swings,
difficulty concentrating,
and changes in ******.
It is also important to
ask if they are having any
postmenopausal vaginal bleeding,
as this could be a concerning
sign for uterine cancer,
among other etiologies.
When obtaining the
breast history, you
want to inquire
if the patient is
having any problems
with their breast.
Have they noticed
any lumps or masses?
any skin changes?
Are they having
problems specifically
at the ******, like
discharge? charge.
Also ask if they
perform a self-breast
exam, including when
during their cycle
they perform this
exam and how often.
Since the breasts are
bilateral structures,
make sure to ask about
each side and document
specifically which side
or both about the presence
or absence of any
complaints or findings.
Questions regarding the
pap smear, which is a
screening test for cervical
cancer, includes asking
about if they've ever
had a pap smear, the last
time they had a pap smear,
and whether it was normal
or abnormal, and if it
was abnormal, did they
have any history of previous
abnormal pap smears?
If they had a history of
abnormal pap smears, what
was the abnormality, and
was there any workup done?
Did they have any
procedures performed?
What type of follow
-up did they have?
All this information
is important so that
the patient is
managed appropriately.
We will discuss
the basics of a pap
smear at the end
of this lecture.
Questions regarding the
mammogram include asking
if they've ever had a
mammogram. If so, when was
their last mammogram, and
was it normal or abnormal?
You also want to ask if they've
ever had an abnormal mammogram.
If so, when was it, what
was the abnormality,
and do they have any
follow-up or procedures?
All this information
is important so that
the patient is
managed appropriately.
When obtaining the ******
history, it is important
that you make sure you're
in an appropriate setting.
You display non-justmental
behavior, and you
preference your questioning
so that the patient feels
comfortable providing you
with this information.
It is also important
not to assume everyone
has been or is currently
******** active.
On this slide is a list of
questions that delve into
their sexuality, the risk
for ****** transmission
transmitted diseases or
infections and overall ******
health. It is important to
understand their ****** orientation
and if they prefer to
have *** with men, women,
including transgender men or
transgender women
or any combination.
If they are ******** active,
it is important to ask
if this is oral, vaginal,
and **** ***. To further
assess the risk of a ********
transmitted infection, you
would want to ask about the
number of lifetime partners
and current partners. You
would also want to ask
if they are using
protection during ***, which
constitutes safe *** practices,
and if they have any history
of ******** transmitted
infections or have any
concerns currently of a
******** transmitted infection.
Additional questions
can be asked to
assess ****** health
including any problems
with arousal ******
and ***********
to begin the discussion
on contraception the best
question is simply to
ask if they are trying
to prevent pregnancy if
they are you want to ask
about what method they
are using if they are
using medication are they
using it as prescribed
for maximum effect
efficiency excuse me efficacy
If they are not using any
form of contraception,
it is important to
understand that if
they are having a
menstrual cycle and are
******** active, they
could achieve pregnancy.
Since they are not
using contraception, it
is important for
them to be taking a
prenatal vitamin daily
in case pregnancy does
occur to help prevent
neural tube defects.
When it comes to family
gynecological history,
the topics you would
ask would include
breast, ovarian, uterine,
and cervical cancer.
We will now discuss
the standard questions
to ask non-pregnant
female patients
regarding their
obstetrical history.
Why do we ask a patient
about their obstetrical
history? We ask to obtain
general health information
and to identify any previous
surgical interventions
that may have they may
have had it also helps to
identify any medical
conditions they may start that
may start in pregnancy and
continue throughout their
lifespan this allows the
physician to have a better
overall picture of a
patient's health and surgical
history if applicable the
first question you should
ask about pregnancy history
is whether the patient
has ever been pregnant if
they have been pregnant
you would like to know how
many times how far along
they were when they delivered,
how did they deliver,
were there any complications
with the pregnancy
or delivery, and if the
children are still living.
You also want to inquire
if they've ever had a
spontaneous miscarriage
or elective termination.
It is important if
someone has had a
spontaneous miscarriage
or elective termination
to understand if this
has been completed
with the use of
medication or surgery.
Although rare, surgery
complications can
affect the uterus and
subsequent pregnancies.
We will now discuss the
standard questions to ask
pregnant female patients
regarding their obstetrical
history, current pregnancy
including postpartum.
In someone who is currently
pregnant, why is it important
to obtain their obstetrical
history? In obstetrics
history can be a good
indicator of the future we
want to identify any areas
of concern that may have
arosen that require special
testing added surveillance
or consultations this allows
the physician to discuss
sensitive topics answer
questions and provide patient
education and anticipatory
guidance on this slide you
see a list of topics to
cover when a patient is
pregnant. This is not an
exhaustive list, but rather it
starts the conversation
regarding the current pregnancy
or postpartum state and
their obstetrical history.
When first addressing
the issue of the
current pregnancy, you
will ask when was the
first day of their
last menstrual period.
You would like to know if their
menstrual cycles are
regular in timing.
You would also ask if
they have confirmed the
pregnancy with a urine
pregnancy test, and if so, when.
Inquire if they've had an
ultrasound in this pregnancy,
and if so, when was it,
and what were the findings.
You will want to obtain
the patient's pregnancy
history as outlined
previously in this lecture.
This is very important
information to know to
make sure the pregnancy
is managed appropriately.
Some common questions to
ask regarding symptoms
in early pregnancy
include vaginal bleeding,
nausea and vomiting,
breast fullness and tenderness,
fatigue, urinary frequency,
and vaginal discharge.
This is not an exhaustive
list of all the
questions you would ask as
a patient throughout the
pregnancy regarding
symptoms and complaints.
With a new pregnancy,
it is important
to assess what the
mother's concerns and
attitudes are regarding
the pregnancy.
You would ask if this
pregnancy was planned
and how they feel
about the pregnancy.
You would inquire
if they plan to
continue the pregnancy
and keep the baby.
You would also want to
get a sense of the support
network by asking if the
father of the baby is involved
and if there are supportive
family members and friends.
during a postpartum visit
you'd want to ask questions
regarding any complaints
or symptoms the patient
may be having ask if they're
breastfeeding or bottle
feeding if they are
breastfeeding you would ask about
any symptoms of mastitis
through the use of
questioning in the edinburgh
postnatal depression scale
you will assess for
depression and anxiety you'll
want to inquire if they're
started their menses yet and
if they have been ********
active since delivery.
Inquire if they're
interested in contraception
or family planning.
You want to make
sure that they follow
up for continued
gynecological care and
routine health screenings.
Remember the gynecological
and obstetrical
histories are documented within
the subjective portion
of a soap note.
We will now discuss the
basics of a pap smear,
including indications for and
how the test is performed.
The pap smear was developed
by George Papanikolaou,
thus giving rise to
the name pap smear.
The pap smear is used as a
screening tool for
cervical cancer.
On a clinical note,
the current
screening guidelines
recommend beginning
pap smears at age 21.
Most cervical
cancers are caused
by the human papillomavirus.
The inferior portion of the
uterus is known as the ******.
The cervical epithelium
consists of two cell types,
columnar and squamous. The
columnar cells line the
inside of the cervical canal,
and the squamous line the
outside of the ******. The
area where these two cell
types meet is called the
squamo columnar junction.
It is at this junction
where 90% of cervical
neoplasia arise. This
is the area where the
pap smear collects
tissue samples from,
including the endocervix,
for further review.
This slide shows you the
equipment needed to perform
a pap smear. You need to
have a speculum as well
as instruments to obtain
the specimen such as a
broom or a combination of
a spatula and cytobrush.
You also need either
a liquid cytology
container or microscope slide.
To perform a pap smear,
you will place the patient
in the dorsal orthotomy
position and insert a
speculum into the vagina
to visualize the ******.
With the use of a broom or
a combination of spatula
and cider brush, you will
obtain the specimen by
rotating the instruments as
depicted in these images.
After you have obtained
the specimen, you
would then take those
instruments and either wipe
them on a glass
microscope slide or place
them in a container with
liquid to be further
processed so that
specimen can be reviewed.
Liquid cytology is the most
common method used today.
Here's a link to
the Scholarax brick
regarding taking
a ****** history.
This slide shows the
objectives we covered
today including what
questions to ask in
the gynecological and
obstetrical histories.
Lastly we discussed the
basics of a pap smear.
This concludes my
presentation. This slide has a
link for feedback and I
would appreciate any feedback
as I continually try
to improve not only the
content of my lecture but
the presentation itself.
Thank you.